Of course, we want to speak the
language eventually and we want to
speak well, however, there's no need to
be anxious about how we're doing now.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about something
that I've been thinking about recently,
and that is the importance of not
speaking the language we're learning.
Don't speak the language we're,
learning a little bit provocative
and I'll explain what I mean.
Meanwhile, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Uh, I click on that
bell for notifications.
If you are listening to this on a
podcast service, please leave a review.
Um, I hope my sound is better.
There have been some complaints
now,.What do I mean by don't speak?
All right.
I'll tell you my, my sort
of reasoning on this.
Um, recently I decided that in my
Arabic, I was going to move over to
Egyptian Arabic because I wanted to try
to understand Egyptian movies better.
Egypt is a country of 90 or more million
people and they have a language with
its own culture, humor, expressions,
uh, which I can connect to in some way.
Uh, that's not true of standard Arabic.
There is no country where the
local language is standard Arabic.
And so it's a little bit
of an artificial language.
It's like Latin or something.
Not quite, it is spoken by many Arabs.
It's spoken in official
situations by politicians.
Uh, the written material on the
internet is mostly in standard Arabic,
but in terms of getting that sort of
resonance that you get from a real
life country, it doesn't have that.
So I started doing, um, you know,
Egyptian Arabic and I found that a couple
of things that were very interesting.
One, my Arabic is now ruined, my
standard Arabic, my Egyptian Arabic.
I have trouble saying anything.
I struggle to say it.
On the other hand, my spoken,
uh, Persian, Farsi has improved
without me putting anything into it.
All of a sudden I have my online
discussions with Sahra and, and she
agrees I'm doing better than ever.
So it's like I left my Persian alone.
I still have, you know, twice a week
sessions with Sahra, uh, but leaving
Persian alone and even leaving Standard
Arabic and stimulating my brain with this
exposure to Egyptian Arabic, with all of
its idiosyncrasies seems to have improved.
My Persian sounds a bit strange.
I have experienced this before that if
you work very hard at language A then
leave language A and go to language B,
come back to language A and you understand
it better and you can speak better.
Why that is?
I don't know.
I have called that sort of
the period of benign neglect.
It may be a function of leaving it.
It may be a function of trying
very hard to learn something else
which is stimulating for the brain.
Then coming back to something familiar
and all of a sudden you're better
able to recall words in that language.
I don't know why.
However, I had a session this
morning in Egyptian Arabic.
I mean, I couldn't say anything,
not in Egyptian Arabic not in
Standard Arabic, but I enjoy it.
I enjoyed it.
And I enjoy listening to the material
that I have in Egyptian Arabic.
I enjoy discovering Egyptian Arabic.
I'm looking forward to being better at
Egyptian Arabic, but I'm not concerned
about my inability to speak right now.
Um, I enjoy these sessions
with Adel Samy my new tutor in
Alexandria, because he's funny.
And he keeps me going and we have
almost philosophical discussions where
he has to give me the words and he
writes the words out on the screen
before I'm actually able to say them.
But that's fine.
I certainly couldn't carry
on a conversation, but
it's extremely enjoyable.
And so the sort of passive, you know,
discovering the language I find enjoyable.
If I were genuinely concerned about
how weak I am in speaking the language,
I would feel, you know, distraught.
And that's why I kind of reminded
myself that, you know, very often
people identify learning a language
with being able to speak the language.
And what can I say now?
And of course we want to speak the
language eventually and we want to
speak well, however, there's no need
to be anxious about how we're doing
now or at the beginning, or even a
fair way along in the language, as
long as we are enjoying the language.
And so, uh, I think very often in
the sort of standard classroom,
there's a tremendous emphasis placed
on producing the language, speaking
the language, which is fine because
that's what people want to do.
But what I think is more important
is what will I be able to do with
them, the language in a year from now?
And from that perspective, I'm not
tremendously motivated to speak.
Now I have this a couple of sessions
a week just to maintain that human
contact with, with someone who
speaks the language, but it doesn't
bother me that I can't speak well.
No, I fully appreciate that there
are situations where we need to
learn to speak the language because
we have immigrated to our country.
And, and when you're in that situation,
of course, you're getting a lot
of input, a lot of input you're
listening and reading all the time.
And you're trying to
speak wherever you can.
And so you have this urgency to speak,
which is fine, but even there, you
shouldn't be concerned about short-term
difficulties in using the language
because it's been my experience.
I mean, I can remember when I was
learning Czech, for example, I was six
months at, at listening to stuff on Czech
history, fascinating stuff about the the
Austro-Hungarian  empire or Prague, and,
uh, you know, under, um, Charles you know,
king Charles back in the 14th century.
And I, I went to this body shop
where the person there spoke Czech.
And I couldn't say a thing.
I couldn't say a thing, but now,
and when I went to, first of all,
now I can understand so much Czech.
I can understand, you know,
what people say and little
clips that I find on Twitter.
Uh, and when I was in the Czech
Republic, I was communicating just fine.
So the point is, again, I guess it's
a common theme that I have is don't
put too much pressure on yourself.
Uh, obviously, if you're in a situation
where you, you need to speak better
quickly, even there fastest path to
that is lots of input activities.
And speaking wherever you have the
chance, but if you are on a, as I
am in the case of Arabic, I have
no immediate urgency to speak the
language I achieve what I achieve.
Twice a week.
I speak sometimes better, sometimes worse.
I focus on input.
I'm enjoying it.
Good enough.
And there could be some surprises.
Maybe if I move on to Turkish and
then I come back to Arabic, all of
a sudden my Arabic speaking ability
will improve as was the case with
my Persian speaking ability after
this period of benign neglect.
So don't be too fast.
I shouldn't say don't speak, but it
needn't be, you know, the objective number
one in the early stages of learning the
language, it's more a matter of what
you feel like doing and what your needs.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.